dann sprechen wir mal mit der
bundesvorsitzendin des Deutschen Bundes
des Bundes des deutschen Landjugend sum
ist der richtige Titel Theresa spitt ich
grüße Sie ganz herzlich in
Berlin ja schön dass ich dabei sein kann
ja schauen wir mal was wir uns zu bieten
haben angesichts dieser Proteste sie
waren ja auch gerade auf dem Protest
Marsch sie wollen dass diese Agrardiesel
Subventionen erhalten bleiben also dass
der Sprit für Bauern und auch für
forstwirtschaftler billiger bleibt als
der normale Diesel und sie wollen auch
dass die Kfz-Steuer nicht angeglichen
wird an die normalen kfzsteuern für
landwirtschaftlichen forzwirtschaftliche
Fahrzeuge sollte das dennoch so kommen
ist das wirklich so eine große
Katastrophe wie gerade dargestellt
wird ja es ist def definitiv
katastrophal das bringt das fast nur
noch zum Überlaufen gerade was unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit angeht wenn wir das
EU-weit betrachten sind wir ja da
abgehängt wenn wir bei diesen Kürzungen
einsteigen und andere Länder um uns
herum ja erhöhen sogar noch die
Vergütung die rückgeführt wird beim
Agrardiesel und erlauben sogar dass man
mit Heizöl tanken kann also das ist
keine Wettbewerbsfähigkeit wie sie die
deutsche Landwirtschaft hier verdient
hat um mal da ein bisschen Butter zu den
Fischen zu geben um wie viel Geld
handelt es sich da was würde da im Jahr
mehr anfallen so grob gerechnet es gibt
ja Rechnung wahrscheinlich ja also wir
sprechen ja von knapp oder gut 20 Cent
je Liter und das kann dann je nach
Betrieb natürlich unterschiedliche
Summen ausmachen aber so die
Größenklasse wie wir sie eben gehört
haben im Beitrag zuvor 6000 € ist da
schon eine ganz gute Maßgabe aber es
kann natürlich auch noch höher ausfallen
und was mir da wichtig ist zu betonen
das ist ja nicht nur eine einzige
Kürzung die wir jetzt dieses Jahr
erfahren haben also das macht dann
sozusagen im Großen und Ganzen noch viel
mehr aus wenn wir auch auf ländliche
Räume und auch auf Tierhaltung schauen
ja das haben wir schon mitbekommen und
wir haben auch mitbekommen so so z.B in
der coronazeit
dass da manches ein bisschen schwierig
war auch die Preisentwicklung für den
Verbraucher wir haben da lernen müssen
dass Brötchen plötzlich sehr viel teurer
worden als vorher auch aufgrund der der
Kriegshandlung um uns herum
und nicht nur Brötchen sondern auch
landwirtschaftliche Produkte also die
gesamte
nahrungsmittelwtscha
Wertschöpfungskette das heißt wir haben
ja insgesamt als Verbraucher schon viel
mehr bezahlt als vorher ist das nicht
beim Bauern
angekommen letztlich kommt viel
wenigeron Bauern an als die Gesellschaft
sich denkt das hängt natürlich klar auch
im Moment mit der Inflation zusammen
dass die Preise steigen und gleichzeitig
ähm hat der Landwirt hier in Deutschland
dann wieder damit zu kämpfen dass die
billigen Importe aus dem Ausland mit den
ja hier hochwertig und qualitativ ja
erzeugten Produkten ja dem
entgegenstehen und so es es gerade auch
beim Agrardiesel wirklich sehr ironisch
wenn die Bundesregierung daavon
klimaschädlichen Subventionen spricht
weil wenn der Agrardiesel und auch die
Grünen Kennzeichen gestrichen werden
dann importieren wir noch mehr Ware aus
dem Ausland mit viel längeren
Transportwegen und auch höheren
Emissionen also das ist schon fast
ironisch was die Bundesregierung sich da
zusammenreimt ja und vor allen Dingen
auch unfairer Wettbewerb oder eine
Verzerrung im Wettbewerb wenn man nun
mal auf auf die EU schaut
eher zu un zu unseren Ungunsten nicht ja
auf jeden Fall sie sprechen die
richtigen Punkte an und gerade um noch
mal bei der heutigen demonstrationsthema
zu bleiben beim Agrardiesel die Steuer
wird ja erhoben um eben auch die
Instandhaltung der Infrastruktur auf
öffentlichen Straßen zu gewährleisten
wir Landwirtinnen und Landwirte fahren
aber meistens auf dem Feld oder auf
Feldwegen und diese halten wir sogar
unentgeltlich instand oder setzen diese
instand also das wird auch nicht
betrachtet da muss ich die
Bundesregierung auch mal überlegen
sollen das denn zukünftig auch die
Gemeinden und die Städte machen also da
ist alles meiner Meinung nach noch nicht
zu Ende gedacht und wir fordern als
jungland Wirtin und Junglandwirte des
Bundes der deutschen Landjugend ganz
klar und ohne Kompromisse dass diese
Kürzungen vom Tisch genommen werden ja
und sie dürfen nun mal so nachgefragt
auch nicht mit ihrem Privatauto wenn es
ein Diesel ist landwirtschaftlichen
Diesel tanken
oder nein nein nein also das ist für die
landwirtschaftlichen Zugmaschinen okay
wollen wir mal schon mal damit auch
abgeräumt haben das Thema ganz kurz noch
zum wie das weitergeht wenn diese
Einschnitte oder Einsparungen oder ja
Wegfall der Subventionen nicht kommt was
dann ist es großer Protest großer
Widerstand größerer Widerstand
angekündigt was heißt denn das ja wir
haben ja heute gesehen wie schnell die
Bäuerinnen und Bauern wie sie es ja auch
eben gesagt haben mobilisiert sind also
das ist jetzt vier Tage her dass die
Meldung rauskam und heute standen wir
hier mit tausenden von Landwirtinnen und
Landwirten und ganz vielen Treckern vor
dem Brandenburger Tor und haben h
richtig Krawall gemacht also das zeigt
ja schon mal wie schnell wir mobilisiert
sind und da ist natürlich nicht aus
zuschließen dass wenn die
Bundesregierung jetzt nicht die
richtigen Entscheidungen trifft und die
richtigen Signale gibt dass da auf jeden
Fall noch weitergeht ja sie haben ja
auch schon eine Fahrzeuge dafür das muss
man ja sagen so ein Traktor aber Spaß
beiseite
es ist ja nun so dass nun viele
irgendwie die Gürtel enger schnallen
müssen in der Bundesrepublik die
Einsparung betreffen ja nicht nur die
Bäuerinnen und Bauern das ist eine Frage
der Solidarität dann für Sie oder sagen
Sie nee das interessiert uns nicht was
die anderen da noch leisten müssen wie
uns geht's nur um
uns das auf auf gar keinen Fall also wir
haben wirklich den Rundumblick wir
schauen nach links und rechts schauen
auf die Gesellschaft und sehen natürlich
auch mit Sorge welche Belastungen
aktuell auf jeden Menschen hier
entfallen was mir nur wichtig ist bei
der Debatte zu betonen wir sprechen hier
bei unserer Bundesregierung von einem
500 Milliarden Haushalt und dann eine
Milliarde das sind ein Sechstel dieser
klimaschädlichen Subventionen komplett
bei der Landwirtschaft zu kürzen die als
Branche die Klimaziele erreicht und da
wirklich gut vorangeht das kann einfach
nicht sein und das machen wir deutlich
heute Morgen und auch in Zukunft diesen
Appell lassen mal so stehen ich sage
ganz herzlich Danke schön fürs Gespräch
Theresa Schmidt vielen Dank